[Música]
lá eu vou falar sobre o poder da auto
medicação o que desde já nos leva uma
grandíssima contradição porque entende
que essa não é uma coisa ruim pejorativa
hoje em pleno século 21 nós vimos isso
com alguma frequência
na verdade a auto-medicação segundo uma
plataforma do ministério da saúde é o
ato de tomar remédios sem orientação
médica
quando isso acontece muitas vezes a
dosagem acaba não sendo específica e
isso como o da noite com os analgésicos
pode levar à intoxicação ações
desencadear alergias e até chegar à
morte
então como isso pode ser benéfico para o
nosso organismo
a resposta é que nesse caso muito
específico o remédio que vem apresentar
não só pode como deve ser aplicado
aliás é um caso muito específico pessoal
não tem que resolver essas outras
questões médicas por conta própria
então já que estou falando de remédio
hoje mais uma vez em pleno século 21
existem alguns remédios nós podemos
tomar para amenizar o distinguir alguns
problemas por exemplo paradores existem
os analgésicos para determinados vírus
aos antivirais para infecções
antibióticos e para febres altas onde
técnicos se for necessário combater a
asma com os antis mágicos podem nos
ajudar e se isso for necessário com a
formação de coágulos
os anticoagulantes também podem exercer
essa função além de muitos outros antes
que estão aí pra isso
assim como nós precisamos transformar o
mundo que tipo de remédio nós tomamos
nessa situação interessante esse que eu
vou apresentar
estou falando pela gratidão mais uma vez
nós temos uma contradição gratidão não
tem a ver com autoajuda autoajuda na
verdade segundo a 3ª edição de 2009 do
dicionário eletrônico houaiss da língua
portuguesa é o ato de fazer uso dos
próprios recursos mentais e morais para
alcançar objetivos de ordem prática e
resolver dificuldades de âmbito
psicológico mas quando a gente fala de
medicina de remédio o aumento não é
psicológico ele é fisiológico então meu
trabalho aqui hoje é por meio de
pesquisas estudos e evidências coisas
que são reais provar que a gratidão pode
sim agir no âmbito fisiológico como
médio que trouxe ao mundo porque quando
a gente pensa em transformar o mundo
algumas palavras usem a cabeça como
sustentabilidade e meio ambiente
preservação mas para transformar o mundo
é preciso primeiro transformar o ser
humano ea primeira prova que eu tenho
disse é uma nova palavra que surgiu
recentemente vem sendo muito discutida e
pode ser incluída nesse grupo
a empatia empatia não é sente pelo outro
é sentir com o outro não é ser herói é
ser amigo
então nós chegamos a uma pirâmide
o objetivo de toda a pirâmide chegar ao
topo dessa nossa pirâmide a mudança do
mundo mas para que nós chegamos a ela é
necessário passar também pela base e
pela internet
a base dessa pirâmide seria a
transformação pessoal do meio da
gratidão por exemplo nós mudamos a nossa
maneira de pensar e portanto de agir com
isso nós impactamos a sociedade por meio
do nosso exemplo da fala como estou
fazendo aqui hoje o ambiente as pessoas
são transformadas e mais pessoas serão
chamadas começam a dar exemplos
isso a longo prazo traz ao mundo mas
para que isso aconteça eu convido você
que está aqui hoje a ver por um outro
prisma e fazer parte dessa mudança
então vamos às evidências se nós estamos
falando de como a gratidão mais de nome
do fisiológico é muito difícil não tocar
em neurociência neurociência o estudo do
sistema nervoso eo principal órgão desse
sistema é um ser fã nem se fala que nós
conhecemos popularmente por cérebro
anencéfalos a quem nós somos e para que
exerça essa função conta com alguns
ajudantes os neurotransmissores como por
exemplo a serotonina ea dopamina
esses dois neurotransmissores
especificamente tem uma função ligada à
gratidão primeira serotonina que é
popularmente conhecida como hormônio da
felicidade é presente em grande
quantidade no aparelho digestório do
nosso corpo no trato gastrointestinal e
quando uma situação de gratidão ocorre a
liberação da serotonina é otimizada isso
significa que ela liberada em maior
quantidade
eu não popular de simone vocês devem
imaginar o que acontece conosco
já o da família gera a sensação de
recompensa de gratidão
quando é liberada no núcleo accumbens
doença
o núcleo que está ali presente por meio
da via isolina isso ocorre quando
acontece uma situação que nós
valorizamos coisas simples do dia-a-dia
tomar um chocolate quente num dia frio
um sorvete num dia quente e ler um livro
depois de um dia de estudo ou trabalho
então pra que vocês entendam a ação da
dopamina e gostaria de pedir que todos
vocês se fechassem os olhos neste
momento e pensar em uma situação assim
coisas simples que vocês valorizam pense
nisso
[Música]
podem abrir os olhos essa sensação que
vocês estão sentindo de recompensa é
causada pela liberação da dopamina que
acabou de acontecer no núcleo accumbens
de cada um
meus parabéns então agora vamos à
pesquisas outras evidências primeiro
internacionalmente falando existe um
jornal britânico chamado nego e méxico
responsável por informar importantes
avanços no estudo da neuroimagem que o
estudo por meio de imagens da
neurociência da qual acabei de falar se
já não promoveu uma pesquisa com o
sujeito depressivos ansiosos pessoas que
na verdade viviam situações bem
complicadas e elas comprovaram que
gratidão uma questão de prática quando
foram submetidas à escrita de cartas de
gratidão
durante três meses nas quais todos os
dias aos expressavam o que acenava
graças ao final desse processo receberam
presentes monetários e foi pedido a ela
que submeter sem essa doação é esse
valor a uma doação o nível da sua
gratidão
com isso foi possível não só quantifica
lá mas registrar a atividade cerebral
que constatou que foi criado um padrão
comportamental
isso significa que mesmo que depois dos
três meses quando as pessoas não tinha
mais o que escrever as cartas ela já
estava grata se tornaram por natureza
agora nacionalmente falando existe um
grupo promovido pela sociedade
brasileira de cardiologia chamado ginga
que juntamente com alguns médicos
renomados estudo os impactos da
espiritualidade na medicina aqui antes
que vocês confundam espiritualidade não
tem nada a ver com religiosidade e
espiritualidade é um conjunto de
práticas como a gratidão a tolerância eo
perdão que a longo prazo trazem grandes
resultados como a pirâmide nós vimos
pois bem esse grupo promoveu uma
pesquisa com infectados na verdade dois
grupos diferentes de infectados que
viviam situações de gratidão e que não
viviam todos eles receberam o mesmo
tratamento o tratamento atual mas os
infectados que viviam as situações de
gratidão tiveram uma recuperação
acelerada em relação aos que não viriam
pois bem nós entendemos portanto que a
gratidão assim como remédio age como um
remédio no âmbito fisiológico que nos
transforme transforma no mundo um
remédio tão necessário nos dias de hoje
que depende de nós para que tenha
eficácia
é gratuito não tem dosagem nem contra
indicação
se isso é tão necessário como as nossas
pequenas atitudes podem contribuir para
que isso aconteça para que a gratidão se
prolifere
nós podemos por exemplo sem graça pelas
pessoas da maneira como elas são
ajustar as nossas expectativas nós
podemos ser gratos pelas oportunidades
que nós temos e ao invés de reclamarmos
pelas nós não temos agir para melhor
aliás se nós somos gratos pelo ambiente
em que nós vivemos aqui falando que é
palpável a árvore chuva
nós somos gratos por tudo isso nós não
destruímos e aí entra um dos impactos da
gratidão no meio ambiente em si mas não
esqueçam com essas pequenas atitudes
vocês têm o poder de mudar o mundo
mais uma vez nós votamos a pirâmide
agora como um fluxograma primeiro nós
mudamos depois empatamos e vemos a
mudança acontecer então eu encerro por
aqui
convidando cada um a fazer a sua parte a
continuar com essas pequenas atitudes
atravessar essa ponte seguir por esse
caminho e ajudar a transformar o nosso
mundo por meio da gratidão e finalmente
agradeço mas não da maneira simples como
nós ouvimos todos os dias agradecendo
pela atenção embora não eu gostaria de
agradecer de verdade dar o exemplo do
que estou fazendo
agradecer primeiro a cada um de vocês
que reserva alguns minutos da sua vida
para ouvir uma mensagem a respeito de
gratidão que deu uma chance a auto
medicação
agradeço aos meus colegas que me
ajudaram durante esse processo os meus
professores a cada uma das pessoas que
nesse exato momento trabalha para que
minha apresentação seja exibida e as que
trabalharam durante o ano inteiro todas
as pessoas que montaram esse lindo
cenário que vocês estão vendo que
trabalharam muito para isso
agradeço a cada um que me ajudou para
que eu pudesse estar aqui e agradeço aos
meus pais agradeço a deus obrigada
[Aplausos]
[Música]